well today happens to be world plumbers
day las vegas is desperately seeking
plumbers yes they are in such high
demand that most students are hired even
before they graduate we caught up with
one trade school to find out about
current trends and discover these
careers are great for both men and women
35 year old jessica ralph is a single
mother of three she got laid off from
her security gig during the pandemic and
went back to school grade school is a
great opportunity especially for women
she enrolled at nti national technical
institute in henderson it offers three
skilled trade programs electric hvac and
plumbing would encourage all females all
women everywhere to
get in nti saw extraordinary growth
during the pandemic we were an anomaly
very atypical we grew 200 percent during
the pandemic campus director derek knee
smith says as businesses were shutting
down and closing many folks like jessica
had to reinvent themselves we've had
doctors we've had strip workers we've
had
gaming attendants
executive chefs and now more than ever
these positions are in high demand every
contractor in the valley basically is
calling or coming by or emailing me
wanting to go ahead and get ahead of the
summer
months for hvac and plumbing basically
is year-round as is electrical
industry-wide a lot of technicians are
aging out and retiring the perfect
opportunity for folks like jessica
absolutely love it it's been
amazing who got hired at a property on
the strip six days after completing the
hvac program at national technical
institute
and while working at her new job she's
continuing her education with the
plumbing certification and will also
tackle electrical next month if you are
interested in pursuing one of these
trade careers tomorrow there's an open
house and job fair at national technical
institute you can meet with instructors
staff and contractors that's from one to
four at nti and henderson off whitney
mesa drive